singer r.kelly is due in court this
afternoon in connection with his six
crimes charges sex crimes charges rather
last week federal prosecutors charged
Kelly with new crimes including paying
off alleged victims and child
pornography those federal indictments
add to similar state charges Adriana
Diaz is outside the federal courthouse
in Chicago Adriana what can we expect
today
good morning tarika well in today's
arraignment hearing a judge will decide
whether Kelly will be released on bail
meanwhile celebrity attorney Michael
avenatti says the new federal charges
involve sex tapes he handed over to
federal prosecutors a vanadis also
offering a potential explanation for why
Kelly was able to walk free after his
2008 trial the fact that he was
acquitted it was bogus attorney Michael
avenatti says r.kelly paid more than two
million dollars to silence a girl and
her parents at the center of his 2008
child pornography trial they didn't
testify and a jury eventually acquitted
Kelly of all charges avenatti says he
represents nine clients related to
Kelly's case including victim's parents
and so-called whistleblowers like a
former Kelly associate who avenatti says
was paid to hunt down a missing sex tape
involving a minor and he specifically
told the associate that his life was
quote on the line the lawyer says at
least two sex tapes are part of the
evidence that could put Kelly behind
bars for life on Friday federal
prosecutors in Illinois and New York
unsealed 18 charges against the
embattled singer accusing him of crimes
against women and girls over two decades
Kelly defended his record with Gayle
King in March and he broken any laws
when it comes to women in a video posted
on TMZ Monday Joycelyn savage and azrael
Clary who say they've been living in a
consensual relationship with Kelly
supported the singer we are just so
thankful for everything
saying and doing and trying to do to
help him now Clary and savage with core
skill you interviewed in March are
expected to attend today's hearing here
in federal court now it's worth noting
that avenatti himself is facing federal
charges related to fraud and extortion
another detail the lawyer offered about
our Kelly is that the singer allegedly
made people take lie-detector tests to
determine if copies of the sex tapes
have been made Gail a lot of layers to
that story thank you very much
Adrianna